Imagine traveling in a foreign country when you learn the news,
if your father's death.
Now imagine that that death means you are now at the helm of the British empire.
This is our Queen Elizabeth.
The second discovered that she would no longer be a princess,
but instead would be the queen of the most powerful empire in history.
She was only 25 years old and would soon become the head of one of the world's
most powerful monarchies,
a post she would hold for much of the 20th century.
Elizabeth wasn't even supposed to be Queen Barnes as the old saying goes,
humans plan.
God laughs.
Elizabeth was born on April the 21st 1926 do the Duke and Duchess of York or
father,
Prince Albert,
who was at that time the second in line to the monarchy following the current
King George the fifth and his older brother Edward Prince of Wales and sure to
her parents or Prince Albert have had a son,
the male as would jump ahead of Elizabeth in the line of succession.
It wants to Elizabeth Sungold Edwards,
the Prince of Wales,
whose behavior alter to this line of succession in love with an American
divorcee Edward abdicated the throne.
In 1936 I made a public uproar about his love life.
Elizabeth's father became King George the sixth and Elizabeth became the next in
line to the throne at the age of just 10 reportedly,
Elizabeth,
his younger sister,
Margaret,
told her,
pour you upon learning the news of the new line of succession now before the
family was thrust into the role of monarchs,
Elizabeth Margaret's and their parents lived a relatively quiet life split
between homes in London and the countryside.
Elizabeth was educated at home by a governess.
She wasn't around children her own age,
with the exception of her sister,
which was a somewhat lonely experience that she tried to avoid for her own
children during these lessons,
and Elizabeth enjoyed learning about history and also showed herself to be a
responsible and organized childs.
She even insisted on properly setting up a toy,
horses before bed each night,
making sure that each was unsettled and fat
as intelligence and responsible as she showed herself to me and Elizabeth still
showed herself to be like many of the children in one regard and that was that
she had trouble pronouncing or name instead of Elizabeth.
She said Lily Beth as a results of the nickname stuck and it was water close.
Family would come to know her as as Elizabeth grew older and became next in line
to the throne,
more emphasis was placed on formal education.
As a 12 year old,
she was taught constitutional history from a member of Eatons faculty and as the
Archbishop of Canterbury,
also religious instructor.
It wasn't exactly what you'd call a typical education,
but there wasn't all dry scholastics studies being the daughter of the king says
and Lee did have its perks.
Do you help Elizabeth Social reach and outdoors.
A Buckingham Palace chapter of the girl guides was started each Wednesday
afternoon.
20 fortunate girls.
Well,
welcome to the panelists to take part in outdoors orientated activities and it's
be part of the future.
Queens social circle,
but alas,
the comfortable innocent childhood of Elizabeth.
It was not the lost coming of age in the 1930s how life would be affected by
World War II before she turns 15 by 1939 England's was worn and do pressure
mountain to send Elizabeth and Margaret to Canada.
Their mother would hear of no such thing.
Instead,
they were sent to live in Windsor Castle in 1940 this mid served two purposes
keeping Elizabeth and Margaret Safer than they might otherwise be in London,
but also helping to show the strength of the country in Italian old,
terrible upheaval and fear.
If England was safe enough for the princesses,
then it was safe enough for the rest of the country too and it's Brits should be
proud and patriotic to do their duty for the war just like the young princesses
were doing.
Now,
while the all sisters were staying in a colossal vans,
were closely watched deva,
that does not mean the princesses were completely exempt from all the fears and
uncertainty that comes with walk.
While they were standing at Windsor Castle,
hundreds of bombs were dropped in the area and like so many of their country,
and then Elizabeth and Margaret who are roused from bed in the middle of the
night,
rush to the bomb shelters and kept on constant alert for the air raid siren.
In October of 1940 at the age of 14 Elizabeth gave a radio address that was
heard throughout England and in North America.
She discussed the situation that she ends.
Margaret,
we're in talking about how they understood what they were evacuated peers were
feeling.
They talked about being separated from their loved ones and living in a world's
turned upside down by violence.
But Elizabeth,
she wanted to do more for her country than just speak on the radio.
She was not yet 18 though and it wasn't until near the end of the walk that she
was given the opportunity to serve as a trainee ambulance driver.
She learns about car repair and it's photos of her working became iconic images
of the British war efforts.
On ve day.
She wore her uniform and stood on the balcony with prime minister Churchill and
to our parents,
and these are the,
she was not yet queen verse even as a teenager,
she had shown herself to be quite the leader
ended in 1945 but its aftermath remains even for royalty.
When Elizabeth married two years after the end of the war,
she purchased the fabric for her wedding gown using ration coupons,
but that didn't mean a dress was a dreary affair.
It was made of silk and decorated with over 10,000 pals or Green Weld.
That was Prince Philip of grease,
a man who'd been in and out of Elizabeth's life since she was 13 years old.
As second cousins,
they saw each other at family functions throughout their lives.
Teenage Elizabeth,
she'd been intrigued by Phillips since meeting him in her early teens,
but it was when Elizabeth was 17 and he was 22 that the prince began to consider
marrying her.
Now,
as we did mention,
they were second cousins,
but such a marriage between cousins is hardly unusual for royalty.
Philip was born in Greece and was a member of the line of succession to the
Greek throne.
However,
he gave up his position in the line of succession to become a naturalized a
British citizen.
The night before their wedding,
he was made the Duke of Edinburgh voting.
They announced their engagement in July of 1947 celebrating the happy occasion
with a garden party in photos from the party.
Elizabeth is unabashedly excited while Prince Philip gazes down at her adoringly
only at four months later in November of 1947 the two were married in a ceremony
at Westminster Abbey,
the Archbishop of Canterbury and York performance,
the right with Roti or realms.
The world in attendance.
200 million common is we're able to listen in via BBC radio broadcast.
After the ceremony,
Elizabeth and Philip with Elizabeth still wearing her wedding gown,
waved to cheering crowds from the balcony of Buckingham Palace.
Shortly after Elizabeth gave birth to their first child,
Prince Charles in 1948 our daughter Anne was added to the family in 1950 it
would be over a decade before and it's a bit of gave birth to her youngest sons,
Prince Edwards and Prince Andrew.
As an interesting aside here,
Elizabeth was serving as queen when Prince Edward and Prince Andrew were born,
which makes her the first queen in England's history to give birth while holding
the title.
It was her husband,
Phillip.
You had the difficult duty of passing the word to his wife that her father had
passed video,
knew he was ill.
In fact,
they were traveling in Kenya because the king was not well enough to travel
internationally,
so his daughter and son indoor took on the duty.
The trip was post doing,
glued to travel to Australia and New Zealand.
Of course,
news of the king's death took priority over all else.
Elizabeth true to the steric stereotype of the British and the discussion.
He,
the royals reportedly did not succumb to her emotions upon hearing the news,
but instead began planning the practical steps for what must come next.
She ends Phillip.
Well,
they returned to England and it was on that plane flight home that she finally
allowed herself to cry.
Although of course she never did this in public.
Even on that flight,
she hid in the bathroom and emerged with red and I,
his buddy composed face years later.
Elizabeth recalled the implications of taking the throne at such a young age.
In a way.
I didn't have an apprenticeship.
My father died much too young.
It's a question of maturing into something that one's got used to and accepting
the fact that,
hey,
you are and it's your fate,
because I think there's continuity is very important.
It is a job for life.
Preparations for Elizabeth's coronation ceremony took over a year and the father
died in February of 1952 but the coronation didn't decar car in till June of
1953 it did rain on the day of our coronation,
but this did nothing to temper the excitement of the day for the British people
who had watched this young women grow up.
Elizabeth was correlated in Westminster Abbey,
bringing her into the line of kings and Queens who had been crowns there for
nearly a millennium,
not even 30 years old.
Elizabeth solomnly delivered to the coronation oath,
which was heard by millions around the world.
The ceremony and a sign of the changing times was the first British coronation
ceremony to be televised in her coronation speech.
Elizabeth,
it looks to the future saying,
yeah,
the following,
I am sure that this,
my coordination is not the symbol of a par and the splendor that I've gone,
but a declaration of our hopes for the future and for the years.
I May,
by God's grace and mercy,
be given to reign and serve you as your queen.
Following the actual ceremony,
Elizabeth and dozens of other dignitaries rude through the streets of London.
She had by adoring crowds,
still more reporting.
Brits stood and cheered hands.
She waved to them from the balcony of Buckingham Palace.
Later in the evening,
Elizabeth and Philip moved into Buckingham Palace after the coronation,
but they did not spend much time there initially.
Instead,
they took off on a weld tour for months of 1953 in 1954 the tall was the
brainchild of a prime minister Winston Churchill.
He recognized the appeal of Queen Elizabeth TV,
the masses and the possibilities.
Sanjay fevered queen presented for building a positive image of England abroad.
They're all a couple.
They went around the wells making Elizabeth fifth first European Monica to so
she was also the first reigning British monarch to visit Australia and New
Zealand and Fiji.
This trip was only the first of many verse Elizabeth would take his queen during
her 65 years and counting as queen that she has become the world's most widely
traveled Monique,
and by the way,
as Queen,
she does have an easier time than the rest of us because of the way British and
international ball works,
which means that she doesn't actually need to have a passport.
If she did,
how they passport though there would be plenty full.
She has made nearly 300 foreign trips.
Do you?
120 countries including,
yeah,
Canada and the United States,
New Zealand,
Australia,
India,
the Muda,
Iran and Saudi Arabia,
Qatar,
Thailand,
Brazil and Russia.
These are but a few of the countries she's visited some of the most notable
trips she's taken into the opening of Canada's parliament.
She's been the honoree at a ticker tape parade in New York City and she's
awarded the Mother Teresa Order of Merit in India and she's also spoken at the
United Nations traveling.
It's been a large part of Queen Elizabeth's reign,
but representing a nation abroad.
Well,
that's not our only duty as a monarch in a constitutional monarchy.
She is tasked with many domestic duties.
Though she doesn't all get involved in politics,
she must stay well informed of what is going on within our country.
Bands around the world each day she receives piles of reading material in case
in red metal boxes.
I think tradition of these red boxes dates in nearly two centuries and until
recently members of parliament also received the parliament's is actually
recently opted to get digital versions of these documents,
but the queen remains tied to paper delivery so those red boxes continue to
arrive daily at our door.
The material contains within encompasses everything from foreign intelligence to
economic updates to the most mundane matters of state reading and digesting.
The information can take several hours a day,
but it is a crucial part of our role as leader.
Even today at the age of 90 she receives her redbox each day and takes the time
to go through the crucial information contained within.
As Queen Elizabeth.
Small public duties include presenting metals,
issuing knighted,
Czanne's presiding over many ceremonies that take place in a society that still
has a queen as she has aged.
Some of Elizabeth's duties have been passed down to our children and to our
grandchildren.
Particularly.
Sarah really is where the nobility received their titles
over the years.
Elizabeth's family grew to include the grandchildren and great grandchildren or
family and despite their royal bloods is has not been immune from the ups and
downs of life and love.
Three of her four children that have been through divorces with the world.
Watching the death of Princess Diana shook the entire family as well as the rest
of the world,
but it was in 1992 when much of the royal family seem to crumble with the
marriages of princess and Prince Charles and Prince Andrew all coming due.
Their ends is in one way or another.
It was also that year that Windsor Castle caught on fire am's.
The public became outraged at the idea that that tax money would be used to
rebuild it.
When the Queen was one of the richest women in the world.
That year,
though,
the queen demonstrated a political acumen when it was announced that the royal
family would pay for the restoration of Windsor Castle Anz and a reversal of a
thousand year old policy.
The family would begin paying their taxes.
Queen Elizabeth,
she has long understood the importance of public opinion.
She's been the power behind him is the British monarchy is increased visibility
in the media.
She realized that the public wants it to know more about the family.
They wanted to feel like they knew the royals.
Increased transparency.
It was one way to help the role.
Family connects with the public and it has long been a hallmark of Elizabeth's
reign.
Hers was the first televised coronation and then she was the first to allow
television cameras into Buckingham Palace.
Five cameras were allowed into the palace during President Nixon's visits and
informal events that included lunch and the swapping of signed photographs
between the world leaders.
Elizabeth also welcomed cameras into the families' lives for the production of a
documentary on the royals.
They think to show them as simply humans who loved their family members,
but it wasn't until 2007 the Buckingham Palace or really go with the times and
launched an official youtube channel.
This was 10 years after perhaps one of the most important displays of
Elizabeth's use of the media to effectively communicate with the public.
Her speech about Princess Diana
when Princess Diana died,
I met the public mourning and the private grief of the family.
Elizabeth broke protocol recognizing that the country and the world needed to
hear from the royal family,
Princess Diana and the Queen.
They were initially close.
In fact,
Diana or even called her Mama.
Let's over time the relationship,
it became the best strange.
Diana regularly broke royal protocol and adds the dirty laundry of her and
Charles is personal lives.
The Queen,
a stoic Monique from the rather different generation did not understand Diane,
his desire to be involved with aids charities or her willingness to talk
publicly about the disintegration off on marriage.
To this day,
the all people like Diana's lover,
dirty fiats father who blamed the queen and the royal family for the car crash
that killed Diana and his son when Queen Elizabeth into family did not
immediately express their grief publicly the press and the people of the Worlds,
oh,
they were pretty outraged.
Eventually the Queen Elizabeth did give a naive address it speaking about Diana
and is the tragedy of her death.
The Queen,
she spoke of Diana in the way most of the world view tar.
First I wanted to pay tribute to Diana myself.
She was an exceptional and gifted human being in good times and bad.
She never lost her capacity to smile and laugh,
nor to inspire others with her warmth and kindness.
I admired and respect you to energy and commitment to others and especially for
her devotion to her two boys.
While public opinion didn't immediately fully rebound in the queen's favor,
the address was helpful and then stemming the tide of criticism.
Unlike her children,
Queen Elizabeth,
she had a long marriage.
She and Phillip have the longest marriage of anyone in the royal family.
2017 actually marks their 70th wedding anniversary.
Then major wedding anniversaries.
They've long been celebrated in England's with that 2050 and marked by a party
that included other couples from around England zoo.
We're all seeing married on November the 20th of 1947 and 2007 the couple
sentimentally returned to that honeymoon site in the Hampshire region of
England.
They like any common,
a couple of May to do.
We created their honeymoon photos
at that 50th anniversary Queen Elizabeth in what is regarded as an emotional
expression for a member of the British monarchy sending this with our husbands
and our marriage.
He is someone who doesn't take easily to complements,
but he has quite simply be in my strength and stay all these years and I and his
whole family and this and many other countries owe him a debt ratchet greater
than he would ever came.
Well,
we should ever know.
Queen Elizabeth is rain now has also been punctuated by your celebrations of
milestones,
not just in her marriage,
but also in the number of reigning years.
The silver jubilee celebrating 25 years of her reign in 1977 what was a
nationwide party marked by sporting events,
carnivals,
concerts,
and general festivities.
25 years later in 2002 golden jubilee.
It was just as Mary have an affair,
even though unfortunately both her mother and sister had died earlier in the
year to mark this occasion.
Queen Elizabeth and Prince Philip traveled around the world in June.
A GBD weekends was hell is to mark the 50 years one events calls or the party at
the palace particularly stood out.
Paul Mccartney and Eric Clapton performance.
It's Brian May play d version of God.
Save the Queen.
It was aim raucous celebration films with some of Britain's most recognizable
celebrities and it was watched all around the world.
Thousands of people crowded London's parks and streets to see that favorite
performers singing along with their favorite songs stands most of all to chair
for that Queen,
very stoic and beautiful Queen Elizabeth.
The second has set herself apart as a modern Monique.
She is well known to be an animal lover,
mentor core.
These are recognizable pass of the royal family hubs almost as much as it's
human numbers.
During her reign,
she has had over 30 cordings as pets that you have even been involved in public
affairs such as the opening ceremonies for the London Olympics.
The he is they.
They haven't always been as cute and cuddly as they look.
At one point,
the role family reportedly had to bring in an animal psychologist to help
improve the dog's behavior when they started at nipping at the many people who
were around the wall residences,
the queen herself was even injured once when she found herself in the midst of
10 fighting Corgis.
These incidents,
they did nothing to temper her love for animals and it's the queen's quarters
will forever be remembered as they are included with Elizabeth's image,
Sean such items as the Golden Jubilee commemorative coins from owning and
pampering core.
He is the Queen has also shown herself to be an animal lover through how
supportive charities among the charities fee support.
Over four dozen it support animals in need.
She is also generous in her donations to medical charities giving to nearly 100
of them.
She also donates money to her church.
Interestingly,
she takes this money to the church in her purse making Sunday the only day of
the week when she hurries money.
Overall,
this is an estimated that the queen's charitable efforts have resulted in over
$1 billion being donated to charity.
Queen Elizabeth for seconds.
She has been the public eye since childhood.
Now I'm in her nineties and to 65th year as queen.
She wants a world leader for much of the 20th century and has helped to usher in
the 21st her reign has spans that have 12 us presidents,
12 UK prime minister's seven pope's and six archbishops of Canterbury.
She has replied to more than 3.5 million pieces of correspondence and received
thousands of birthday greetings throughout our lifetime.
She has that with leaders from all corners of the wells and surpassed the
longevity records of both British and foreign Monnox.
She is one of only funny of British monarchs who have ruled for more than 50
years.
And in 2015 she became the longest reigning British monarch.
Previously that title had been held by Queen Victoria.
Elizabeth is Great,
great grandmother who reigned for 63 years.
Queen Elizabeth the second,
she's an icon of the 20th and 21st centuries.
A strong female leader who retains our love of our people and the strong
standing in the international community.
She helps bring the [inaudible] into the modern wells and remain stoic and
dutiful through even the most trying of times.
God Save the Queen.
So I really hope you enjoyed the video.
If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button below and don't forget to subscribe what our
brand new videos twice a week.
And as always,
thank you for watching.